back here on the rich eisen show after i
guess we we missed last year
due to everything that went down with
the virus but march
madness with the first four tipping off
tonight and then
the field of 64. through the lens of cbs
sports and turner sports
joining us here on the rich eisen show
to help me fill in my brackets is clark
kellogg how are you clark
rich great to visit with you and um i'm
doing great
healthy and safe as is my family i trust
you can say
the same thing just
flooded with gratitude and excitement to
be able to
do something we've done for decades and
weren't able to do last year because of
the
coronavirus pandemic so just um just
extremely grateful
excellent and excited to be able to step
into this
um three-week run to a championship i
feel the same exact way clark so
all right let's start baylor versus
hartford go you thought i was kidding i
really need you to help me fill up my
bracket
well you got that one you don't need me
you don't need me for that one
i like the bears i actually like the
bears to come out of the south
i know my alma mater the buckeyes are
there and they've been really good
resilient tough all season long coming
out of the toughest conference in the
country in my opinion but
i i like baylor because of what i saw
mid-season early season from that team
and i think with the benefit of a few
extra days of practice leading into the
tournament
um they will get back to that early
mid-season forum when they were
um clearly one of the most dominant
teams in the country alongside with
gonzaga and we we do have that part of
the bracket up there in the south region
it's just
both of those uh 8 9 and 5
12 games of the south region are in the
same bracket as obviously the top seed
right there and to me
you know those are the games in the
first round that
always leap out at me for a highly
competitive contest that could actually
give the one seed a run for their money
or the 12 seed that ends the season for
a five seed which is always you know
obviously somebody that hasn't won their
uh conference but somebody who did have
a nice run in their conference maybe in
their
conference championship game out of the
5 12 and 8
9 games that are out there which ones
leap out at you starting with the 8-9
that could actually give a one seat a
run for their money
in this term you know what's interesting
um they may not give illinois a run for
the money but
it would be an intriguing matchup if
loyola chicago was able to
get get by georgia tech who's been
playing extremely well although
georgia tech lost at least for this
first game they lost uh moses wright
um i think colgate-related issues and
he's not available so
um i targeted that eight-nine matchup
was just one that was intriguing and
also the potential
for the second round on the other one
that that really intrigued me was lsu
saint bonaventure
um lsu is an elite offensive team that
sometimes struggles defensively
the bonaventure bonnies are an elite
defensive team
that can control pace that just
stylistically
could be a really fun one to watch and
either one of those teams
could be a problem for a michigan team
that
likely plays this tournament without
isaiah livers i'm an all big ten forward
who does a lot for them
um so those were the two that they kind
of jumped out at
me i know everybody will look at north
carolina wisconsin because those are
a pretty strong brand names and they've
got sides that could give baylor some
problems but
i like the bears to to be able to handle
that um
next round uh reasonably well yes and
you know
trust me when i saw lsu and eight seed
uh after
almost winning the sec tournament
against you know
alabama which is uh if i'm not mistaken
is the two seed within that that's
correct region as well i'm sitting here
thinking
with michigan being banged up like that
uh that that that eight seed for lsu
seems to be a little bit low
who else has been seated lower than you
think
uh just looking at this bracket writ
large going into the first four tonight
morgan
oregon is a little low to me
at seven not terribly so and you know
you can go a line or two either way
but oregon would be kind of a dangerous
team i think at that 7c
stylistically how they play
i tell you what in terms of another team
that
may out play at sea um
the georgetown hoyas
they might outplay that 12c rich um
they i had them twice one time i was
doing it remotely when they came back
and beat providence and i was in gamble
pavilion
um two weeks ago when they lost to yukon
and got handled pretty easily
but they that run through the big east
tournament the way patrick has them
playing hard those seniors
um pickett and blair and bellay
have really started to have the positive
side of senioritis
where they're playing with nothing to
lose with great
confidence and abandon and on a mission
and don't discount the
factor of john thompson jr
leaving us dying this summer patrick
ewing
coaching at his alma mater i mean those
are galvanizing elements that sometimes
can
help a team make a make a special run
through the tournament how about that
one too clark right
now georgetown with patrick ewing and
madison square garden i know
you know a lot of the actual basketball
was lost amongst patrick wondering why
he uh
you know with a very rare for patrick
ewing don't you know who i am
type moment you know uh about his
credential needing to be presented
in the building in which his uh
credential is actually hanging in the
rafters you know
um right yeah but what a great i mean
that is just amazing to me that ewing is
maybe in the role of
1985 villanova in a way come on now
you're coming home now what are you
doing
hey hey hey that's not um that's not far
fetched i can see how you can connect
those doctorates
right see it you know oh yeah oh yeah
yeah man
that's part of what makes this time of
year um special because you know
something like that is going to happen
somewhere perhaps and
why not the hoyas why not the hoyas the
the 12th seed the 12 seed now villanova
in 85 was the eighth seed before
obviously taking out those uh those hoya
destroyers back in the
back in the mid 80s so what about so
we've talked about michigan being a
banged up one seed we talked about
illinois and you mentioned about baylor
obviously
we're all talking about gonzaga which
enters as i guess the strongest number
one certainly the top
seeded team out of all the number ones
and uh the opportunity to go
undefeated we've been waiting for mark
few to cut down a net do you think this
is it and they're gonna go undefeated on
the season
in the process clark i do i picked them
in the bracket that i had to reveal
after the selection so well in the last
segment of our selection show on sunday
and i picked gonzaga
um it would be a phenomenal story
on many levels from the standpoint of
one we haven't had an undefeated
national champion since the indiana
hoosiers in 76
but two amidst the backdrop of the
pandemic
mark few and gonzaga have been uh big
time
a big time program i mean they're elite
as a basketball program
they don't they maybe have the
championships that
kentucky and carolina and duke
um kansas others have but clearly in
this
last 15-year period they've been right
on the same
level of those schools in terms of
production and wins
sands the championship so how
appropriate and fitting would it be
if in fact they got it done to do it
in this circumstance in an undefeated
fashion and they're clearly capable
not any discernible weakness that i can
pick up
other than maybe a team can slow them
down grind them to a halt make them play
half court
would they be able to grind out that
kind of game
i say they could but that would be the
one
area where um i might hesitate but
i think um they deserve the overall one
seed and they're clearly the top
favorite
in my mind to win it all and the reason
why others might not believe that is why
they still can't get over the fact that
it's a small school from the state of
washington that perhaps
much of america that might not be as
attuned to sports because of the
pandemic let alone college basketball
would hardly
even see play an entire half let alone
an entire game
is that is that are we still are we
still behind that
i think no you know i think part of it
and there's still a pocket of folks
out there who follow the game closely
that um
give some credence to the fact that the
conference isn't the big ten
or the sec or the big 12. the big ten
and big 12 were clearly
the top leagues in the country by
representation and by quality of play
top to bottom
and so that would be the one thing that
those who are not
in the camp of gonzaga being able to do
it that would be one of the major
pillars of defense the conference
doesn't challenge them enough but
gonzaga challenges themselves in the
non-conference schedule to the degree
that they could have it this year
and prove more than capable of playing
against them beating anybody and i don't
think that changes
because it's the tournament clark
kellogg of cbs sports will be
in a studio with greg gumbel and the
rest of the crew including wally zerbiak
as part of the
cbs sports turner sports hybrid coverage
of the
ncaa tournament i asked this question
from my guy
chris brockman across the way plus we
also forget uh because we missed last
year
uh how how far does syracuse go because
nobody's seen the match-up zone before
and jim behind goes off his usual magic
cards the elite eight or the final four
sweet 16 at least it's just like has
nobody
seen the way he plays defense out of the
90 years that he's been doing it with
ronnie cycling right so i mean
so how does that happen this year hey
it's just one of those quirky things i
mean jim behind is
obviously i mean he's been doing it a
long time he's had unbelievable success
and knows his team and knows the game i
mean i love
hearing him talk basketball he keeps it
really simple but they've got a real
challenge
i think against san diego state this
team
is coming off a year last year where
they were going to be a relatively high
seed
on this team defends at a high level
they've got two seniors and matt
mitchell and jordan shackle that have
led them
extremely well shot making and play
making and they've got other pieces i
think
san diego state prevails in this first
round match up against syria
although the zone will um take some
adjusting to but i i think san diego
state has enough
um defensively and offensively to move
on in that matchup so if it's so
when when the score is eight to four at
the third television timeout of the
first half
we'll know san diego state's in trouble
is that basically what you're saying
no no as a matter of fact if it's kind
of a grinder i think san diego state
would be fine they'd be comfortable with
that yeah they would
they don't have to explode i mean
they're a solid offensive team but they
hang their hat
defensively okay rely on the play-making
of um
mitchell and shackle and so i think
they'll uh
low scoring wouldn't be a problem okay
um for the aztecs
all right couple more questions left for
clark kellogg here on the rich eisen
show
um the first four tonight you've got
uh two games of 11 seeds two games of 16
seeds
um the one i guess with the the most
blue blood
in it is ucla versus
msu spartans presented by rocket
mortgage um
is that the game that leaps out to you
uh this evening
clark no doubt no doubt clearly
as a matter of fact my partner seth
davis on sunday night you know
he had the bracket he and greg got him
yep we actually all got him
probably 30 minutes before our show but
i tend not to look at him until we
actually
reveal him to the public i just kind of
like not seeing him early
but he had already lost his mind
when he saw that match up as a first
floor and he almost blurted it out
against my wishes so yeah that one as
soon as i did look at the
see that one come up on the screen i was
like whoa that's
um but hey though both of those teams um
are in
and clearly they were not in by much so
that's an intriguing
um first four match up and i haven't
filled out my bracket completely yet
rich because i want to see
who wins that one that's the only spot i
haven't filled out because
i think michigan state could give um
byu i'm assuming byu a little more
trouble than ucla mike
all right just kind of wait waiting on
that one okay and then uh
last one uh give me the cinderella give
me the the the one if you could peg
well you gotta define cinderella for me
okay let's see has a different
definition for cinderella
all right so somebody uh six seat or
lower
uh and i choose six because i think
that's what my wolverines were in
seattle in 1989.
um so six seed or lower that
um that goes the distance cuts down the
nets
or even final four i'll even i'll even
uh lower the bar
slightly even though it's clearly still
uh very
high in the sky who do you think has the
opportunity to catch some fire
go the distance and make a run here to
the final four
i um i didn't really see a six or lower
seed getting to any final four but if
you're going to
force me to choose one which you are
doing this on your show yes sir
what do you think i like i like the
cinderella element of the hoyas
i'll go there because they've got
they've got some um
shot makers the young point guard dante
harris is really starting to
grow in confidence and there's something
special about the grit
that patrick ewing brings to his team
and that they take to the floor
so uh and that region i love florida
state though but there are four seats
therefore seed
i take texas as my um non-number one
seed to get
to um lucas oil stadium for the final
four but if i hadn't picked texas it
would have been florida state i didn't
go
below the six line but if i had to i
would
i would mean um halloween georgetown and
then give me a couple first round live
this for the last question first round
upsets
what do you think i like uc santa
barbara okay i
like the match-up with creighton and i
love the team they defend they've got a
great player in jakoy
mclaughlin he's terrific um
i think villanova is going to survive
against whitfield they're going to find
a way even without colin gillespie but i
like utah state
over texas tech as well all right those
are some good ones
and then i guess that last one for you
is how do you think the pandemic in the
bubble is going to affect the way this
goes
and by that i mean do you see we we
might see
better play because there's no travel
involved there's just gonna be
uh they're just gonna stay there and
they'll be on a regular
sort of home if you will um
practice schedule do you think um we'll
see a little bit better action
or or more upsets or uh just wondering
if this is going to be any different in
any way shape or form you think based on
the circle
you know that's a great question i'm not
sure but i do
believe that we've had a pretty good
quality of play all season long as i've
watched games and i've watched
three digits worth of games over the
year over this season so
i think the quality has been
surprisingly good across the board
i think that continues um i
just don't know where kovid might rear
its head
with the team in a significant way
thinking of moses wright and georgia
tech for instance right
will we have two or three more of those
with
teams that would really suffer from the
loss of a player that's
the one expert but i think quality of
play and the excitement
i think all that we've come to enjoy and
love about
march madness will be on display i just
i don't think there'll be any added
advantage for
um not traveling and having it in one
place i don't think that i just think
we're going to have similar to what
we've had with the um
outlier of covet maybe
showing up in unexpected ways
once the tournament starts and that
could disrupt some things but otherwise
the game
the drama the unpredictability quality
of play i think all of that will be
uncomparable to what we missed
from last year all right um you got me
all fired up clark kellogg i look
forward to seeing you on my television
screen miss seeing you do what you do
last year and let's catch up during the
tournament i'd love to have you
yeah look forward to getting back enjoy
the madness it should be a
run like no other fantastic clark
kellogg at clark kellogg cbs on twitter
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here